những cái lúc như này là chỉ có mình mới cứu được con mình
thôi đó mấy bà
nên là phải học thuộc lòng phải lắm chắc như bắp í đó
để mình có thể tự cứu con mình
khi mà em bé nhà mình có dấu hiệu bị sặc một cái
là mình bắt đầu có thể là Cho em bé nằm nghiêng luôn
vỗ vào giữa cái 2 sơ mỏi vai
đây là sơ mỏi vai của bạn ý chia đôi Ra vỗ vào đây
đó nếu như thấy bạn ấy khóc là như thế này đã ô kê
nhưng mà nếu như thế này nếu mà thấy bạn ấy vẫn không khóc
ho sặc sủa tím tái không thở được
thì ngay lập tức là phải đỡ bạn ấy dậy nhá
dùng 2 cái bàn Tay của mình đỡ lấy cằm bạn ấy nè
nghiêng bạn ấy xuống
để xuống đùi như này trúc xuống
cái đùi của mình nó phải thấp nha
cái đùi của mình nó phải thấp
đầu bạn ý thấp hơn mông đó
sau đó thì mình sẽ dùng cái góc bàn Tay như này mình ấn
ấn xuống như thế năm lần
ấn xuống như thế năm lần sau đó lại ngửa bạn dậy
Cho bạn dậy này
ở giữa 2 cái hạt vừng của bạn ấy
mình sẽ lấy 2 cái ngón trỏ của mình
ấn vào đây 5x1 2 BA 4 năm
mình phải dùng lực một chút nha
làm tiếp tục Cho đến khi mà sữa hoặc là dị vật
nó bắn Ra ngoài